la minuscule planète mercure à peine
plus grosse que la lune qui effectue un
passage devant l'énorme soleil le
spectacle visible de bouddha l'eau des
deux amériques a débuté à 7h30 ce matin
il s'est poursuivi jusqu'à 13 heures ça
phénomène extrêmement rare en
astrophysique qui se produit simplement
treize ou quatorze fois par siècle
les images captées par les instruments
très sophistiqué de la nasa était d'une
grande beauté
on y voit mercure franchi 1.4 millions
de kilomètres en moins de cinq heures un
tout petit point noir qui semble flotter
sur un océan de feu une traversée qu'on
ne reverra pas avant 30 ans je trouvais
que c'était un privilège de voir
phénomène que je risque de ne pas revoir
dans ma vie heureusement pour la poignée
d'astronomes amateurs qui avaient
accepté l'invitation du planétarium rio
tinto de venir observer mercure en plein
air les nuages qui recouvrait montréal
depuis ce matin se sont retirés durant
une heure les instruments mis à leur
disposition pour repérer cet objet qui
se trouve à près de 5 millions de km de
la terre ou fait leur boulot ça nous
permet de voir de façon une façon plus
plus réel que l'image de robben sont
presque trop belle l'observation des
passages de mercure a déjà permis il ya
très longtemps de déterminer le diamètre
du soleil entre autres choses mais
aujourd'hui l'événement astronomique est
considéré avant tout comme une curiosité
scientifique y en a comme un petit
intérêt scientifique à pouvoir tester
les les outils et les instruments pour
pouvoir étudier l'exoplanète en fait est
de le faire sur le système solaire est
de servir du système solaire comme
laboratoire proches avant d'aller
observer des choses qui sont beaucoup
plus loin à 13h04 mercure était disparu
des écrans et pour ceux qui ont raté le
rendez vous patience le prochain n'aura
pas lieu à 20-30 ans ici norma grondin
radio canada montréal